Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am going to
explain an American science fiction thriller film
called “Awake.” Spoilers ahead!
Watch out and take care!
Jill Adams is a former U.S. Army medic and a
recovering alcoholic. She works as a security
guard in a local medical college to raise her
kids, Noah and Matilda. At the beginning of the
movie, she enters the hospital at night and uses
her privileges to sneak into the research lab.
She then steals some medicines and sells them
to a local drug dealer the next morning.
After the adventurous morning, Jill goes to her
mother Doris’ house to pick up her children.
Because of Jill’s past with drug abuse, Noah and
Matilda are currently under Doris’s custody by
law. Matilda is delighted to meet her mother but
Noah, like a typical teenager, seems grumpy. Doris
sees them off but asks Jill to bring the kids
home by seven. As they drive, the car swerves and
stops by the side of the road. The mother asks her
kids if they are okay but before they can reply,
a car hits them and sends them flying into a
lake. The family struggles to get out of the
flooding vehicle. Jill and Noah somehow manage
to swim up but notice that Matilda is nowhere
to be seen. To their relief, a policeman has
saved her and has brought her to the shore.
Jill is hurt, so the policeman suggests she go
to a hospital. He reveals that the entire city is
going through a power crisis and everything that
works on electricity or gas is malfunctioning.
All the vehicles in the city have
stopped working out of the blue,
which has caused several accidents everywhere.
Jill and the kids rush to the hospital,
only to see that it is packed because of cases of
accidents. No one knows what caused the power loss
or when it is going to come back but the people at
the hospital speculate that they might be at war
or are being attacked by a terrorist organization.
As the family waits for someone to attend to them,
they witness two patients who were in
a coma, waking up at the same time.
They come back home and stay at Doris for the
night. Noah and Jill cannot fall asleep, so they
look at the stars through the window and notice
satellites moving at high speed. The following
morning, Jill cycles to work. Even though it is
still pretty dark, everyone in the neighborhood
is awake. She is confused because normally
the streets are empty at this time of the day.
Before going to work, she goes to her drug dealer,
who tells her that he can double the price on
any pills she can provide as the sales are
skyrocketing because of the power loss.
At work, Jill takes the risk and tries
stealing medicines in the broad daylight.
She is caught by the college’s chief Dr. Murphy
who walks into the room with two soldiers.
To Jill’s surprise, the last thing they
care about is her stealing the medicines.
They are preoccupied with finding the cause
of the power loss. Doctor Murphy remembers
that Jill used to be a medic, so she asks
her to join the survivors’ hub established
to research the power loss. Jill declines the
offer, wanting to be with her kids instead.
An employee from the college named Brian tells
Jill that no one in the city has been able to
fall asleep for the last forty-eight hours. They
are unsure what is causing it but it is almost
as if the power loss eradicated human’s ability
to fall asleep. Brian explains the severity of
the situation claiming that people will soon
suffer from the symptoms of sleep deprivation,
and if this goes on for long enough everyone
will lose their minds. Jill doesn’t believe him
because Matilda slept peacefully the entire night
and was fast asleep when she left for work. Brian
is shocked because the only known person who has
slept in the past forty-eight hours is an old
woman with heart disease. The doctors have been
studying her symptoms in the hopes of finding
a cure for the condition. Jill realizes that
Matilda and the woman are the only exceptions
in the entire city. Brian asks Jill to take
Matilda to the hub to help the doctors,
but Jill declines, fearing the experiments that
the doctors will perform on her daughter.
Following that, she rushes home to look for
Matilda but finds out that she is in the church
with Doris. Everyone at the church has been told
that Matilda can still sleep. The pastor gives
a sermon about Matilda being a beacon of hope.
Now, the extremists present in the Church want to
sacrifice her in the hopes of getting their sleep
back. Back home, Jill senses that Matilda might be
in great danger if people find out she can sleep.
So, she packs up a bag of necessities, deciding to
run away from society. She and Noah make their way
to the Church and Brian tags along. On their way,
they witness several robberies take place. They
also come across the dead body of a police officer
in an alleyway. People have already started
going insane because of sleep deprivation. Jill
finally reaches the Church and hears the people
discuss if they should sacrifice Matilda.
Brian tries to convince the people to let her go
to the hub and help the scientist develop a cure,
but a police officer who is in the favour of
sacrificing her shoots him dead. Everyone panics
and starts running around. Amidst the chaos, Jill
manages to get her children, and the three run
to a nearby forest. Noah convinces Jill to go to
the hub because if he and Jill die in a few days,
people will kill Matilda. While discussing their
next move, Jill realizes that some old models
of cars must still be working. So, they go to a
nearby garage to find one. Noah and Matilda hide
outside as Jill carefully walks inside the garage.
She notices two thugs have looted the place
and are planning to claim all the cars as their
own. Jill walks further inside and manages to get
the keys, all while staying hidden. After finding
a car that works, they start their journey to the
hub. A while later, Matilda sleeps on the
back of the car. Given the circumstances,
Noah is astounded by his sister’s ability to
sleep. They stop the vehicle when they see
an accident in the middle of the streets. Jill
walks closer and notices the thugs from earlier
have been killed in an accident. She simply
takes their gun and continues the journey.
A while later, they come across a bunch
of naked people, presumably from a cult,
standing in the middle of the road. To Jill’s
relief, they leave space for the car to pass.
The family then reaches a secluded
library and decides to take a rest.
Jill teaches Matilda to shoot a gun claiming
that she will need it after Jill and Noah die
of sleep deprivation. The thought of being alone
terrifies Matilda. Later, she is sleeping outside
in the car while Noah and Jill are trying to
locate the hub on a map. Several prisoners are
let free from a nearby prison because of the
crisis. A prisoner named Dodge finds the car
and drives away with Matilda still inside of
it. When the other two come outside, they are
surprised to see that Matilda missing. To add to
their problems, the other prisoners surround them,
asking Noah to come over. Jill runs out of bullets
and the criminals are about to capture them
when Dodge drives the car back to the library.
He saves Jill and Noah and drives away.
Moments later, they stop near the plane wreckage.
Dodge finds several clothes and other necessities
in the wreckage, after which they head north
to the hub. At night, Jill teaches Matilda to
drive to prepare her for the possibility of living
alone. While they are at it, they notice people’s
dead bodies hanging upside down by the side of the
road. Jill hurriedly tries to drive away but the
maniacs outside break the car’s window and grab
them through it. As they struggle to stay inside,
Matilda presses the gas and they somehow
manage to drive away. Some hours later,
they finally reach the hub. Jill and the kids
hand the car over to Dodge so he could drive
to his hometown to meet his family. He offers to
stick around to help them, but they decline.
Jill then keeps Noah and Matilda hidden in a
house, because after everything that happened
on the way, she wants to make sure the hub is
safe for her children. The sleep deprivation
is starting to get to her. She approaches
the hub while hiding under a bridge. She
finds out that the army protecting the hub is
surviving on medicines but slowly, they are also
turning violent. Jill disguises herself as a
lab worker and meets the old woman who is the
only person that can sleep other than Matilda.
Jill wants her to raise Matilda since only she
has a possibility of surviving. But the woman is
too sick and old to understand her request.
She reveals that she was supposed to be dead last
month but is somehow still living. Just then,
Dr.Murphy enters the room and sees them talking.
Jill claims that she is there to help. Murphy is
also visibly affected by the lack of sleep. She
says that the doctors have found a drug that helps
the sleep-deprived brain function better for a
short period of time, but it also harms the brain.
Jill returns to the house and sees that
Dodge, Noah, and Matilda have been found
by the soldiers. Dodge had come back to help
them, but now all of them are at gunpoint.
To save their life, Matilda tearfully admits
that she can sleep. The soldiers then take
her to the lab. The researcher, Dr. Katz exposes
her to an anesthetic gas and is surprised to see
that she can actually sleep. Jill has now lost
her rationality because of sleep deprivation
and exhaustion. Murphy asks her questions about
Matilda but she can hardly form a sentence.
Following that, the old lady goes into cardiac
arrest and passes away despite the doctor’s
effort to save her. Now, the fate of humanity
is in Matilda’s hands. Dodge is taken as a guard
and is given stimulants to help with exhaustion.
Meanwhile, Jill experiences hallucinations where
she sees Noah trying to kill her. She comes
back to senses when a soldier takes Noah away,
who was beside her the whole time.
As time passes, everyone at the hub, including
the medical staff and the soldiers starts to lose
their minds. They experience hallucinations and
shoot everyone around them. One of the soldiers
calls Jill, Sandra and tries to kill her. Moments
later, she shoots herself dead. Then, they start
killing each other. Jill rushes to save Matilda
but Murphy stops her. Some seconds later, she dies
because of the stimulants Dr. Katz has given her.
Jill finally frees Matilda, and they run to save
Noah. Noah, on the other hand, is hallucinating
too. He touches an electric wire, believing it to
be a fish, and gets electrocuted in the process.
Jill and Matilda try their best
to save him but to no avail.
The following morning, dead bodies are
scattered all around the establishment.
Everyone has died except for Matilda and Jill.
Yet, Jill is not in her right senses and is
about to pass out anytime soon. Suddenly, Noah
wakes up alive and well. The two are surprised
and overjoyed to have him back. They notice that
Noah seems to have come back from a deep sleep
and is now normal. Matilda registers that
Noah could sleep because he temporarily died
last night like she did when she drowned in
the lake. In an attempt to save their mother,
the kids bring her to a nearby lake. They
push her into the water, waiting for her
to stop moving. When she goes limp, they bring
her out and try to revive her. The movie ends
as the kids perform CPR on their mother.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on the notification, and leave a like to
help the channel out. Thanks for watching.